hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well for many of us
among the most important relationships
that we have are those that we in these
days called family relations or
relations to those who we see as related
to us a lot of times we talk in terms of
blood or genetic relationships but we
might also well think about adoptive
relationships and how those function as
well Aristotle doesn't leave this out in
fact he thinks that it's quite important
to talk about this within the framework
of friendships or feel the I and he's
interested in in one part of nikka
mechanics book 6 in talking about how
affection and he uses two terms fairly
you know synonymously there both of
which are Burke's standard game which
means to field-strip with familial
affection later on Astoria is going to
be formed out of that which gets
associated with one kind of long later
on feeling you know the verb also
FaceTime to the middle or passive verb
for feeling friendship feeling affection
all of that how does that happen what
are the basis for that within these
familial relations Aristotle discusses
this in part because he's interested in
how this works but he's also looking at
what should be
with a family so we might think in terms
of this is providing us with a idealized
model but also you know giving us some
scope for thinking about how things
sometimes go wrong parent study says
feel this naturally for their children
and he doesn't go very far in his
discussion of this he says that they
feel affection for their children for
their offspring and is essentially part
of themselves we often say that you know
somebody who's a child resembles their
mother or their father or you can see so
much other their you know child is so
much of the parent in the child you know
we can go out of that and so when you're
actually the parent and you can see some
of those traits they have might help to
produce the the affection you know the
child is actually from you aerosol says
at least the mother does this is a
common concern for the ancient Greeks
before paternity tests became readily
available you know there is an old
saying that only the mother can know
that that she is actually the parent and
so here so this is why the mother is I
actually love their children that
fathers do which is a little bit suspect
but he says that they you know they're
the more attached to their their their
progeny than the progeny to them because
that which Springs from a thing belongs
to the thing from which it Springs he
also says that parents love their
children longer than the children love
that in in duration why because the
parent begins to feel this immediately
after the child is born and the child
were their firstborn I mean if any have
seen babies when they're newly born
there they don't know much of anything
and so Aristotle says until the child
has developed some degree of
understanding or at least you know
perception they don't really understand
I'm the parent that says parent and
we'll talk about that a little bit more
and if it stays as parents love their
children owes as themselves one's
offspring being as it
another self and this is where this
notion of friendship as being about
another self comes in now you could say
well what about when the child begins to
develop a personality of his or her own
you know the child becomes you know
mature and and develops their own
individuality that is no longer entirely
dependent on that parent aerosol doesn't
tell us much about that but we can
imagine that would work along similar
lines as with other friendships and some
of the things that we're seeing here
with the other discussions would fit in
there
parents and children have spent a lot of
time together so that also allows for
that bond of affection to grow between
them you know he doesn't talk about the
fact that parents might also be driven
nuts and and dislike their children
because their children do resemble them
and because they're talking do come from
them if you have a bad character traits
you know I'll sort of let's say in
attentiveness or a lack of common sense
and now you see that in your child you
might dislike with the seeing that of
your child and if you're not very
emotionally mature you might dislike
your child because of what you dislike
in yourself children pick up a lot of
habits from us and they are in many
respects you know reflections of
ourselves so if we don't really like
ourselves if there's traits about us
that we don't like that our children
pick up a that can be a problem let's go
on to talk about children Aristotle says
children feel this this feeling of
affection towards their parents as being
the source of their their being as
having been what brought them into being
and this is a very typical agent not
only Greek but also Roman many ancient
cultures have this sort of view the the
parent is in a certain way analogous to
like I'd put here the gods the divine
because the parents provide what makes
existence possible for the child
first of all bringing the child into
being and then sustain the child in
being as the child is growing sometimes
quite a long time so you know the
children you know whether their parents
really are good or superior to them the
children will often look at their
parents as being something like divine
figures with you know being superior
being good being one that the image of
the good is this is also why it's so
important when you're parenting to be a
good person because otherwise you could
really screw your kids up by giving them
the wrong example because of this
affection the affection can work to make
the kids think that the wrong things are
right and in case he says the appearance
of bestowed on children the greatest
benefits of being the cause of their
existence and their rearing and later of
their education so he says another
important point of this the friendship
between parents and children affords a
greater degree both a pleasure and
utility or usefulness than of a person's
unrelated to each other even as much as
they have much in common in their lives
so by living within the same household
you know just think about the function
of chores for example right at a certain
point your kids can take the trash out
and now you don't have to do the trash
and then it's so nice because up until
that point not only have you been
watching the kids and doing all the
things necessary perhaps for you earning
an income to take care of the kids and
shoveling them here and there you're
also doing all the household chores when
your kids become old enough to actually
do the chores and not just do them but
do the correct something you don't have
to clean up after them suddenly you know
they can become useful for you you've
been useful for them the entire time now
they become useful for you and there's
that at that level there's lots of ways
in which we derive pleasure in the
parent-child relationship as well you
know think about things as simple as
when the infant is there playing
peek-a-boo kids love that right and
parents kind of like that too I think
there's many other ways you know
spending time together the sort of
things that parents good parents will
often do with
reading together going fishing going on
trips you know provider that you know
meltdowns or things like that the things
that we talk about is building memories
right well they also don't just build
good memories those build off of that
affection and deepen it and widen it so
that now philia encompasses something
more than just hey I don't want to
brought you into this world let's talk
about siblings now so siblings also feel
this for each other and the original
basis of this is that they are coming
from the same being so here are some
will thinks that you know stepchildren
for example or our children who are
adopted from different families will not
have that original bond of connection
with each other of course they might if
they think that they're actually from
the same parents and they're not told
about that but then over time there's
other factors that enter in as well like
you know the rear of the education the
common experiences he has a great
discussion here about a virtue he says
friendship between brothers is the same
characteristics as members of a
comradeship and has them in a greater
degree provided they are virtuous
provided they are you know decent people
you know that they are morally serious
we might say that they have something
that we can look up to and he goes on
and he says it as much as children of
the same parents who've been brought up
together and educated life are more
alike in character more like in their
basic assumptions more like in the way
that they live together provided they
haven't been brought up in a bad way
they will naturally inclined to each
other they will naturally feel a greater
degree of affection towards the Torah
towards each other then they will
towards outsiders or even members groups
that they they belong to so he says also
with brothers
test of time has been the longest and
most reliable you remember that the
highest form of friendship for Aristotle
required is that you have spent a lot of
time with that person you can already
have put that time in with your sibling
at the times when you were actually most
vulnerable to being a screw-up that is
youth from the heddle essence and
perhaps early 20s right and if you made
it through that you have this this huge
stock of experience you know somebody
might might say you don't really know me
but if you grew up with them you
probably do know that pretty well you've
had observed one other thing that I
didn't put on the board Aristotle says
that that relations with other family
members who are not so closely connected
like cousins are really analogous Tunes
of these sorts of relations they're just
not as as strong they have to do with
coming from a common stem but then also
how often you interact is is important
as well so somebody might have first for
instance in my family first cousins are
really much more similar to what other
people have as brothers and sisters
third cousins are much more like what
other people in today's society have
those first cousins were a sort of older
family in that sense and we also make an
effort to to stick together and stay in
touch other families don't necessarily
have it you might be first cousins with
somebody and you don't know them from
Adam you don't really feel any sense of
affection towards them so that that's
important to keep in mind the last one
we want to talk about a very important
husband and wife Aristotle says that the
the mating instinct originally brings
people together man
woman right he's not worried about you
know other possible relations keeping
things very basic here you know
reproduction generally took place as far
as we know there may have been an
exception I don't actually know if
there's ever been but it's taking place
primarily man woman getting together
getting together because of the sexual
love
action that Aristotle says is natural we
observe this not only in human beings
but in many other animals as well so he
says the friendship the the philia
between husband and wife appears to be a
natural instinct because human beings
are by nature a peering creature this
was even more very interesting even more
than he is a political creature now
Aristotle says that human beings are by
nature political or social creatures
here he's saying even more than that we
are caring creatures we are creatures
that are looking and he doesn't just
think it's about getting laid about
getting me rocks a lot for something
like that that has a role in it but he
thinks that we're looking for something
more than that so he goes out of his
senses
whereas other with the other animals the
association of the sexes aims only at
continuing the species human beings
cohabit stay together not only for the
sake of beginning children but also to
provide for the needs of life it is a
relationship in which both partners get
something out of it so like I put a
common life together he says with the
human race division of labour begins and
man and woman have different functions
they supply each other's wants putting
their special capacities into the common
stock now this is rather idealized I'm
not saying that Aristotle is right about
this in thinking that every relationship
goes this way whether in the present or
an aerosol time or in the prehistoric
past that we think of a lot of
exploitive and unfair relationships what
Aristotle is saying that when affection
is arising it is arising in part because
of whatever measure of you know fairness
or equality of putting things into the
common stock is involved he thinks that
is part of what cements the relationship
of friendship and
between spouses between people who are
staying together he goes on and he says
the friendship of the man and wife seems
to be one of utility and pleasure
combined by the way aerosol doesn't
think that that friendships of utility
and friendships of pleasure very often
combine they do combine here in the
marriage or sponsor relationship so
that's very interesting he goes on
though and he mentions another
possibility he says it may also be based
on virtue if the parent that's the
partners be of high moral character for
either sex has its special virtue and
this may be the ground of attraction it
may be that some romantic relationships
they're going to be pretty rare are in
fact relations of people who are
virtuous with each other and then he
says children to seem to be a bond of
union there for childless marriages are
more easily dissolved children are a
good possessed by both parents and
common and common property holds people
together children help too you might say
expand and consolidate the affection
already felt in their relationship
between the woman and the man the the
wife and the husband in the relationship
so what we have here is a whole you know
you might say economy within the
household for the circulation of the
affection that is important with
friendship again Aristotle is not
actually claiming that this is the case
and every single family as a matter of
fact we know that's not actually the
case perhaps from our own bad
experiences or from seeing other people
who we know or at least watching
lifetime movies but this thumbs provide
us with a great model and a way to for
understanding how affection is supposed
to arise what its basis are and then how
these different relationships are
connected with each other